the jurgen experience and so in that
situation and i'm probably kind of
giving away too much information because
the video's not out yet but
i think it's necessary so the guy walks
in he says he's robbing the place he
hasn't shot anyone yet
but
he starts arguing with another person
and the other guy is supposed to be like
a new conceal carrier and then the guy
stands up he's like yo what is your
problem what are you doing he's kind of
angling towards his gun but he's not he
hasn't gone for it yet the other guy has
a gun too the guy who came in to rob the
place but he hasn't pointed his gun at
anyone he hasn't shot anyone
so at that point
theoretically speaking you could argue
that's just mutual combat
yeah right so which one can i shoot
who's actually endangering who right
right so i ended up shooting a guy who
came to rob the place the problem is
i shot him in the back too
but that was from the standpoint of when
i decided to shoot
i know how to shoot so i dropped four or
five rounds just
naturally right into the guy he he's
like oh [ __ ] he turns around because
he's getting shocked as i'm shooting him
so he turns to run so is it like a laser
that sets off like a half a haptic
feedback so you're wearing a vest right
it's called a stress vest so you're
wearing a stress vest until it sends out
sends out a later laser every time you
hit that person and it shocks you and
does it shock you like a taser does it
shock is it as bad as you want it to be
really so you can you could get it to
the point where it mobilizes your body i
don't think it gets that high i think it
gets to the point where you're like okay
get this thing off me have you ever been
tased no i haven't either but i've
watched people get tased and i'm curious
because some people can just [ __ ]
handle it they can't
are they usually high
i don't know
good question i think sometimes they're
high but how does that stop your body
from shutting off due to the electricity
that is true
that i don't know because i've seen
people just get
zapped and they just stand there and
they just pull the [ __ ] right out of the
body now this is one video guy did that
um the cop was being very patient with
the guy um and he he's at them nothing
and he's like all right he's at him
again he dropped really second time he
dropped so i don't know what plays what
part you know yeah i don't understand
that's outside of my wheelhouse honestly
my friend dana white um he uh went
for one of his shows they they all got
tasered
and uh they felt like they their body
just shut off like
they just fell over see i'm not the
funny thing about this i had to stress
fest on too
so when i was doing it so the whole time
i'm like i don't want to experience this
yeah so yeah so if you hit you turn it
yeah
hmm yeah yeah i'm i'm curious to what
that's like i'm sure it's horrible
you know i mean i'll put it like this
when i shot him he yelled
[Laughter]
our food is pretty bad yeah but you know
from that perspective i still ended up
shooting him in the back
hmm
now is that legal um because he's not
you are not in danger you're just acting
almost like as law enforcement
or or as protection
so in that particular case once we broke
it down my shooting was justified right
um but it just goes to show you how thin
that line is between justified and
unjustified and it doesn't it also like
well in that situation was there cameras
involved because it's in a store yeah
but what if you're in a school like in
the school situation
like if you walked in and shot that guy
who was killing those kids and you shot
him in the back clearly you'd be
judgmental
because you're that's in defense of a
third party okay right um so at that
point all bets are off like whether i
shoot you in the back front side but i
guess the argument that could be made in
my particular situation is he was
retreating right right because he was
running out that's why i shot him
because he turned to run away and so it
was basically it happens really quickly
right and the split times between my
trigger pull pretty fast so it's like
right you know that time period he can
turn and catch one in the back but you
get an aggressive enough prosecutor
that's the argument they made if i was a
prosecutor that's the argument i would
make you know about the um the case in
austin
um where a guy was not he was not
charged for a long period of time but it
was at a
one of the protests
during the pandemic and this guy
apparently was military and he was an
uber driver he was uber driving
yeah so he pulled down this road i think
he was following his gps and he pulled
down this road and all of a sudden he's
faced with the the people that were
blocking the road
and this guy pulls an ak-47 out and
points it at him and he shoots him he's
a veteran i mean he's he's used to being
in you know live combat situations and
he just pulls out his gun and shoots him
and shoots him
did he get charged he did get charged
i don't know
let's find out what the status on that
was because all my friends that are law
enforcement or military were furious
that he got charged because this guy
literally pointed the gun at his face
yeah like he's standing there
pointing the gut
what are you gonna do it's like how do
you know if the guy's gonna kill you or
not like it's unreasonable to point a
gun at a person in that scenario do you
know what that's you know what that
speaks to
what edu [ __ ] education dude like i i
in my videos i say this time and time
and time and time again
we have over 400 million guns in this
country man you're not getting away from
the guns you're not and if you take them
away from legal people that have them
legally only people are going to have
them yeah are the people that have them
exactly and so if we understand that
this is the country that we live in we
have a second amendment we understand
the culture in this country why do we
not spend
just even a decent amount of resources
on a federal level and we'll say local
level to teach people
the dynamics involved with firearm
ownership let me ask you this um one of
the people one of the things about
people that are pro second amendment is
they don't want to change
any of the restrictions or any the way
it's set up right now they want to keep
it exactly the way it is in terms of
what kind of background checks exist or
they don't want to add any sort of
additional checks
any sort of additional restrictions
why is it so easy to get a gun license
because efficiency but why is it so hard
to get a driver's license because people
suck at driving but don't people suck at
shooting some do a lot of people a lot
of people do the difference though too
is we're talking about a constitutional
right versus a privilege when i had got
a concealed carry permit i had to go
through an extensive examination and
which also involved showing that you are
proficient at shooting
why don't people have to do that well
because we are talking about a
constitutional right right so the
standard is a lot different than say
okay we're giving you the privilege to
drive this car on the road so like with
the car i can own any car i want
if i private property i can drive all
over that private property without any
education without any instruction or any
of that stuff now the moment i want to
step out into the public with this car
and drive it on public roads that's when
i have to get licensed get registration
and all of those things okay i see what
you're saying so if someone wants to
have a gun and they want to take it
somewhere then they have to go through
these examples generally speaking so
like but not it used to be the case in
texas now no now we have constitutional
carry which means that you don't have to
go through those those procedures in
order to carry a firearm so here's the
story uber also released a statement
unfortunately we are unable to comment
on pending litigation this is about the
guy who is an uber driver as we've
released uh in the past this incident is
not related to the uber platform says
for now this gentleman perry remains
indicted on multiple charges including
murder in this case
in august his attempt to get the murder
charge dropped was denied
um from what i understand this is uh has
to do with the district attorney in
austin
that they uh you know we have a lot of
very liberal district attorneys in this
country they just uh repealed the guy in
san francisco to screams and cheers of
people who are dealing with
unprecedented crime and homelessness
there
and give me a start in san francisco oh
you're the one who told me about it
you're the one who explained to me the
whole homeless situation and we've
talked about it multiple times and and
credited you with explaining it you know
since you're a lawyer and you understand
like the
you understand like the inner workings
of the machine in a way that i probably
don't be honest with you you know what
got me to understand it wasn't me being
a lawyer it was me being on the ground
and seeing the [ __ ] and talking to the
people that's what really set it off for
me because when i was with the nra we
were doing these many documentaries
going to these different places and
talking to the people on the ground
they were explaining stuff to me you can
watch the video you see it in my face
like i'm like the same way you reacted
the same way i reacted when i first
heard it i thought it was a funding
thing i thought like do we need more
money for homelessness and then when i
realized that it's a business it's like
a light bulb went off when you explained
it to me i was like of course
it's like everything else when you
showed me the numbers and the people in
la making
260 thousand dollars a year to deal with
the homeless situation and it's not
going anywhere i'm like that person has
a [ __ ] great job you know i actually
analogize that to the issue with gun
violence in the inner city
how so so
it's a theory
um do i have concrete data to affirm it
nope but
i think to a degree
a lot of these leaders and politicians
in here in the city need that violence
in the inner city to continue as a way
to justify the necessity for them being
in place in the positions that they're
in like what kind of position so
um
if you think about the vast majority of
the gun violence in this country is from
the inner city
overwhelmingly so the numbers are crazy
like when when people talk about gun
violence in this country maybe we should
start with that right gun violence in
this country when you look at gun deaths
a gigantic percentage of them are
suicides yeah right i would say about 65
63 to 65
are suicides okay so when we're talking
about gun violence i mean i am not
clearly i'm not in favor of suicide yeah
you know obviously i want people to get
help and and live happy lives but
this is not
my main concern my main concern is
people harming other people so when we
look at the numbers of gun violence it's
always exaggerated because they don't
include the fact that
that is uh they're starting to do it now
they didn't before yeah how do you hear
about it on fox news yeah like they
legit i remember because this was like
at the the genesis kind of of my my 2a
advocacy when i was looking at the
numbers because i kind of
initially just took the numbers for what
they were and i just assumed because you
hear gun violence you see you hear gun
deaths you're thinking people shooting
at other people in middle street and
dropping debt right
and then i started looking into the
numbers and i started realizing wait 63
to 65 percent of suicides and like point
out it's not that i don't care about
suicides but then i also backdoored and
i said okay well let's look at the
suicide rate just as a whole
in america versus other places that have
strict gun laws and i remember when i
was on bill maher and i was sitting at
the round table we kind of started
getting into that discussion
and you would think considering we have
as much as many guns as we have in this
country in the hands of civilians you'd
think
on the surface we'd lead the world in
suicides
we don't not even close
so that begs so that stands for reason
that the issue with suicide isn't a gun
thing it is purely a mental health thing
yes right so that's why i'm able to okay
let's set this aside and now deal with
what's remaining
then you have a very small percentage
that are accidental gun deaths right um
we're talking about like maybe totality
in a year a thousand
and what percentage is that i think it's
like if i remember correctly it's like
three to five percent okay or something
like that so and
we're almost at 70 then yeah we're at
like 68 and that's including and then
there's another percentage that includes
officer shootings
whether it's officer shooting a criminal
or criminal killing an officer right um
so we can put that here over here as
well because that's a different dynamic
what percentage are officers that's
sitting somewhere in about the also two
to three percent i'm probably flipping
it i don't know if the accidental gun
deaths are about two to three and the
officer is like five if i'm not mistaken
um but we can find out we could jamie
will pull it up so we could get an
accurate assessment of it but
to get to where we want to go is
essentially homicides with firearms
that's where we want to be and generally
speaking that you've got a range of
about eight to twelve thousand people
every year die from actually being shot
by another person that includes mass
shootings everything right and then what
percentage of those are gang related
so
because the whole gang related because
now what's happening is they're taking a
lot of the gang-related shootings and
including them in mass shootings
it's just kind of like what happened in
philadelphia recently right
they called the philadelphia shooting
and just happened recently a mass
shooting what was the philadelphia one
uh it was basically there was a shootout
between i don't know how many people it
was but um there's a there was like i
can't remember exactly where in philly
it was but essentially i came a lot of
people got shot um
and they called it a mass shooting it
was street violence that's what it was
it was it was two parties going at it
and they call it mass shooting
i can i guess
you could argue why that that's
considered a mass shooting but it's not
but in our minds we think about it a
mass shooting is somebody you have an
individual or multiple people who want
to go and kill as many innocent people
as possible right right we're not
talking about people who are shooting
each other over disputes this was a
dispute that took place in the public
between two people with guns essentially
and then so they want to call that a
mass shooting
and i'm like that's not fair because the
way the deal with these types of things
is it's different the same way you don't
include the suicides in the homicides
because there are different reasons for
why they're happening
right and so a lot of the vast majority
of the gun violence the homicide aspect
of it is from the inner cities
that's where it's coming from it's these
kids literally when i say kids i'm
talking like 17 18 19 20 21 year olds
they're shooting each they're shooting
at each other
now i'm not dismissing that and saying
that it's irrelevant and that we
shouldn't be we shouldn't factor that in
what i'm saying is it's a totally
different reason for why it's happening
it's not a gun issue it's a social
economic issue because if you take those
same kids that look like me
right i know a lot of i know i know a
lot of black people of color who live in
the suburbs of america and they're not
running around committing drive-bys and
bmws
they're not so what's the difference
there they have access to guns the same
way these kids have access to guns and
these kids have access to guns illegally
in the inner city
the difference is prolonged exposure to
poverty
but nobody wants to have that
conversation the reason they don't want
to have that conversation because it is
admittedly hard to deal with it's hard
it's convoluted and it's difficult